today I'm really excited because I'm
going to be going through a little
musical montage unboxing of the Star
Wars advent calendar and the best part
about this is this to Luke from dad I
can't get over it I also got one of the
festive holiday sets so I'm going to be
putting that together hopefully soon
here for you guys are you ready come and
get it
no no no no oh okay how's this gonna
work a table I got a table I have a
table but there's stuff on my table
leave nice
so now comes the fun part putting it all
together obviously with these advent
calendars you're not supposed to just
completely open them up and destroy the
box like I did but that is how I roll so
now I'm going to cut into if this entire
box so that I can get the instructions
on how to build said things then
supposed to build just like ironing
about that measuring life I'm not about
that instruction life but I am because I
don't know how to put it all together so
we're gonna we're gonna put those stuff
together that I was there's all the many
figures that came with the advent
calendar set you guys are so cute